¿Teléfonos móviles?
¿No?
Creo que todos sabemos que nuestra zona
de confort está destinada a ser algo natural, al aire libre;
en una playa, cerca del fuego.
Donde estamos leyendo o comiendo, o tejiendo.
Y estamos rodeados de luz natural y elementos orgánicos.
Las cosas naturales nos hacen felices.
Y la felicidad es una gran motivadora, nos esforzamos por conseguir la felicidad.
Quizás es por eso que siempre estamos rediseñándolo todo,
con la esperanza de que nuestras soluciones se perciban más naturales.
Así que empecemos aquí
con la idea de que un buen diseño debería percibirse como natural.
El móvil no es muy natural.
Y probablemente piensen que están adictos al móvil,
pero en realidad no.
No estamos adictos a los aparatos,
estamos adictos a la información que circula a través de ellos.
Me pregunto cuánto tiempo serían felices en la zona de confort
sin ninguna información del mundo exterior.
Me interesa cómo accedemos a esa información,
cómo la experimentamos.
Estamos pasando de un tiempo de información estática,
guardada en libros y bibliotecas, y paradas de autobús,
a través de un periodo de información digital,
a un periodo de información fluida, en el que
sus hijos esperan acceder a cualquier cosa, donde sea y en cualquier momento,
desde física cuántica hasta viticultura medieval,
desde teoría de género hasta conocer el tiempo de mañana,
solo como si encendiesen una bombilla.
Imaginen eso.
A los humanos también nos gustan las herramientas simples.
El teléfono no es una herramienta muy simple.
Un tenedor es simple.
(Risas)
Y no nos gustan hechos de plástico,
por la misma razón, tampoco me gusta mucho mi móvil,
no es así como quiero experimentar la información.
Creo que hay mejores soluciones que un mundo mediado por pantallas.
No odio las pantallas, pero no las siento
y no creo que nadie se sienta muy bien
sobre todo el tiempo que pasamos encorvados sobre ellas.
Por suerte,
las grandes compañías tecnológicas están de acuerdo.
Han invertido mucho en tacto, voz y gestos,
y también en los sentidos,
en cosas que pueden cambiar objetos mudos, como las tazas,
e infundirles la magia de Internet,
convirtiendo esta nube digital
en algo que es posible de tocar y mover.
Los padres, preocupados por el tiempo de uso de pantallas,
necesitan juguetes físicos digitales que enseñen a sus hijos a leer,
así como tiendas de apps seguras para la familia.
Y creo que, en realidad, eso ya está sucediendo.
La realidad es más rica que las pantallas.
Por ejemplo, me encantan los libros.
Para mí, son máquinas del tiempo, átomos y moléculas enlazados en el espacio,
desde el momento de su creación hasta el momento en que los experimento.
Pero francamente,
el contenido es idéntico en mi móvil.
¿Entonces qué es lo hace esto... una mejor experiencia que una pantalla?
Quiero decir, científicamente.
Necesitamos pantallas, por supuesto.
Les mostraré un vídeo y, claro, necesito la pantalla enorme.
Pero pueden hacer más cosas con estas cajas mágicas.
El móvil no es la policía de la moda de Internet.
(Risas)
Podemos construir cosas, cosas tangibles,
usando la física y los píxels,
que pueden integrar Internet al mundo que nos rodea.
Les mostraré unos pocos ejemplos de ello.
Hace un tiempo, acabé trabajando para una agencia de diseño, Berg,
en la exploración de cómo sería una Internet sin pantallas.
Y nos mostraron de varias maneras cómo
la luz puede trabajar con los sentidos simples y objetos físicos
para traer de verdad Internet a la vida, para hacerlo tangible.
Como este asombroso reproductor de YouTube mecánico.
Y esto fue una inspiración para mi.
Después trabajé con la agencia japonesa AQ
en un proyecto de investigación sobre salud mental.
Queríamos crear un objeto
que pudiese recopilar datos subjetivos alrededor de los cambios de humor
que son tan esenciales en los diagnósticos.
Este objeto capta el tacto,
así que quizás lo aprietes muy fuerte cuando estás enfadado
o lo acaricies si estás relajado.
Es como un palo de los emoticones digitales.
Y entonces puedes revisar esos momentos más tarde,
y añadirles un contexto en línea.
Más que nada,
quisimos crear una cosa bonita e íntima
que pudiese vivir en el bolsillo
y ser querido.
Los prismáticos son, en realidad, un regalo de cumpleaños
por el 40º aniversario de la Ópera de Sídney.
Nuestros amigos de Tellart en Boston trajeron unos prismáticos turísticos,
de esos que puedes encontrar en el Empire State Building,
y los adecuaron con una perspectiva de 360 grados
de otras vistas icónicas de patrimonios de la humanidad...
(Risas)
usando Street View.
Y después los plantamos en las aceras.
Así que se reconvirtieron para su uso más simple y físico,
o para ser portales a esos otros iconos.
Por tanto puedes ver Versalles o la Cabaña de Shackleton.
Básicamente, es realidad virtual de 1955.
(Risas)
En nuestra oficina usamos pelotitas de ropa para intercambiar URLs.
Es increíblemente sencillo, como la tarjeta del bus.
Básicamente introduces una web en el pequeño chip de aquí,
y después haces así y... ¡bumba!
la web aparece en el móvil.
Cuesta unos 10 céntimos.
El Abrazárboles es un proyecto en el que trabajamos
con "Grumpy Sailor and Finch", aquí en Sídney.
Estoy muy entusiasmado con lo que podría pasar
cuando apartemos nuestros móviles y pongamos los bits en los árboles,
y mis hijos puedan tener la oportunidad
de visitar un bosque encantado guiados por una varita mágica,
donde pudieran hablar con hadas digitales y hacerles preguntas,
y que les respondieran con preguntas.
Como pueden ver,
estamos en la edad del cartón con esto.
(Risas)
Pero estoy muy entusiasmado
con la posibilidad de devolver a los niños al exterior, sin pantallas,
pero con toda la poderosa magia de Internet al alcance de la mano.
Y esperamos tener algo parecido a esto funcionando para finales de año.
Así que recapitulemos.
Los humanos preferimos las soluciones naturales.
Los humanos amamos la información.
Los humanos necesitamos herramientas sencillas.
Estos principios deberían ser la base del diseño en el futuro,
no solo para Internet.
Quizás se sientan incómodos con la era de la información a la que nos movemos.
Quizás se sientan desafiados, más que simplemente entusiasmados.
¿Saben qué? Yo también.
Es un periodo realmente extraordinario de la historia humana.
Somos la gente que ha construido nuestro propio mundo,
no hay inteligencias artificiales...
aún.
(Risas)
Somos nosotros, diseñadores, arquitectos, artistas, ingenieros.
Y si nos desafiamos a nosotros mismos,
creo que podemos conseguir una zona de confort de verdad
llena de la información que nos encanta
que parezca tan natural y sencillo como encender una bombilla.
Y aunque pueda parecer inevitable
que lo que el público quiere son relojes, webs y aparatitos,
quizás podríamos pensar en corcho, luz y pelotitas de ropa.
Muchísimas gracias.
(Aplausos)